hey on today's show we're going to be
talking about family and sleep anxiety
i'll be talking about
a woman who loves her husband but he
just won't get a job and he won't tell
his mom to stay away
we're going to talk to a woman whose
family members have no integrity and she
doesn't know what to do
we're going to talk to a lovely woman
who's so heartbroken because her
marriage has fallen apart
stay tuned hey what up what up this is
john
and this is the dr john deloney show a
live show where we talk to you about
your life
your challenges your victories the
things that are going well the things
that are not going well
we talk about it all in the show
anything and everything
whatever's going on in your heart in
your mind in your neighborhood in your
country
give me a call we're all in this
together all of us
right and on this show sometimes we
highlight what is going
right in the world i got this email from
natalie meyer skyra shira
s-c-h-i-r-a natalie meyer she-ra
i think that sounds cool i'll go with
that natalie writes i am a teacher of
english in iowa is there any more
english teacher statement than i am a
teacher of english
in iowa well done natalie she says
i so love your request for stories of
people being kind and living life well
thank you appreciate the shout out i'm a
daily ride share user
and not long ago a driver and i had the
following exchange
the rideshare driver who has driven me
several times says
hey natalie can i say something i don't
want to offend you
at this point i can't wait to hear
what's next natalie responds
of course you're not going to offend me
to which the rideshare driver he says
the outfit you were wearing yesterday
was really pretty
and that's the end and natalie writes
that was so kind and observant not
offensive
and we're living in a weird world where
we train people especially men that they
need to be worried about offering a
simple
platonic compliment the pressure of
knowing when to say what and how to say
it can be immense
so i just want to take a moment to
celebrate that driver
he not only made the effort to be kind
but found the courage to take a risk in
order to do it
may the blessing of his kindness return
to him many fold and may wait
we in each our own way follow his
thoughtful
example natalie you are awesome
rideshare driver you leaned into the
discomfort
and you had to say it and my guess is
natalie was having a one of those days
where she felt a little rushed
she felt like she had stuff on her mind
and you recognized
man she looks pretty today and she could
use a compliment
and you held out that first day man and
then you leaned into the discomfort and
said
i want to invite myself into a quick
compliment
i don't want to be offensive but you
look nice
thank you man thank you for the tiny
little winds of common human decency
common human decency i love it thank you
so much for sharing that natalie
and thanks to everyone for sending in
their positive stuff here's the deal
we talk about everything on this show
from relationships to mental health
issues
to good stuff to tough stuff to hard
stuff
all of it whatever's going on in your
life give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-6900
you can also email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com all
right let's go straight to the phones
let's go to samantha in minnesota good
morning samantha how are you doing
good morning dr d i'm fantastic how are
you
the exact same exact same i am i am
fortunate to be
up and it's sunny outside and i'm
talking to my friend
in minnesota how are we doing well i'm
good first i wanted to say
that i am so grateful to have you on my
team
at ramsey solutions well thank you for
taking that position
thank you so much listen to the dave
show every time i'm in the car
so very cool very very very cool yeah
it's been a it's been a hoot and a total
life change so it's been fun yeah
so how can i help i'm going to get to
get down to it here for you all right
my sister's dog needed to have an
emergency
c-section your sister's dog
her dog oh this is already awesome this
is already awesome go ahead
so she came to me and she said i have a
huge favor to ask you
she knows that i don't do debt i she did
fpu with me
and she said i have a huge favor to ask
will you co-sign
on care credit for me
i hate being in this situation
because i don't do that but i also don't
want to let her down and
i told her okay here's the deal like how
much do you need
i have my thousand dollar emergency fund
i'm in baby step two
so um i also have another thousand
dollars that i was going to put towards
that so i have two grand what do you
need
and she said to me no no i have the
money to pay for it
but i want to have the payments
uh this blew my mind yeah because why
not and okay
yeah and um so i said
okay fine you know i said yes to
co-signing
thank the lord it did not go through um
and then wait hold on before we go there
so the the loan was denied
with you as coach as a co-signer correct
and i don't know why but it was denied
because somebody was looking out for me
i think
um no it sounds like it doesn't sound
like someone's looking out for you it
sounds like
either her credit and your credit are
both so terrible that
they you all couldn't get approved for a
loan for
a dog yeah the weird thing is that both
of our credits are around
the 700 so wait it doesn't it didn't
really make any sense
okay all right so we're on to the next i
don't want to get distracted i can get
distracted today
so she's on the phone with my mother
after this complaining about the
situation
and i'm sitting there and my mom says i
thought
that your sister was going to help you
with this and my sister says yes she
tried it didn't go through
and you know she wouldn't take out a
credit card for me
and i just sat there in silence and then
my sister goes on to say
maybe i'll just try to take a card out
in my daughter's name my 11 year old
daughter's name
and what i got there
and did not know what to say and
um i've heard this talked about on the
dave ramsey show a little bit
i know it's illegal to do that and
yeah it's fraud from my perspective i
didn't really know
if it was my place or what to
so i just sat and quiet but i just i
guess my question is how do i handle
how do i handle that it blew my mind the
whole situation yeah
i and i can see that at some point you
have allowed your sister
and or your mom to
totally run the way you feel about you
where did that start where does that
even come from
how i feel about myself about you yeah
why why do those two people and i can
understand your mom
but why do those two people have so much
power over you
that is a really good question i haven't
thought about it how old are you
i am 29. samantha you're almost 3-0
yo so here's how you know
30 by the way yeah of course well not
not now you're not if you keep
co-signing for
for pet surgeries but here's the thing
here's how that call would have gone to
my house
um and i'm i'm i am a
i'm not a special guy okay it would have
gone something like
yeah you know deloney won't take out a
credit john won't take out a credit card
for me
and i would have responded with yeah
because i'm not an idiot
idiot and then whoever brother and
sister i would have had would have
laughed and then i would have laughed
and said are you being serious right now
that you have
money and you're going to choose to put
a pet surgery
not even a credit card on a personal
line of credit
that is you need a co-signer for
um for puppies that you can't even i
guess afford to
to keep etc etc and it would have been a
glorious moment for me to have um
fun and ingest because my brother and
sister and i are super close and we love
each other
but it would have been fun making city
it would have been all over them
because i don't have i haven't i've
absolutely not given them that power and
if one of them decided to rattle me to
my mom
about yeah because you know john won't
help me he won't take out a credit card
for me
i would have been banging on pots and
pans going yes
because i'm not an idiot and then
and then here's the crux of the question
and i think you're getting at
if i hear my brother or sister
going to one of their kids and saying
i'm going to commit
fraud and use their credit card or use
their social security number
to get a credit card to pay for
anything much less a dog surgery
dude i'm getting all up in everybody's
business because i have made it my
business
to care and love for children in my home
and in my community period and
i would be ringing the bells if i were
you because here's the thing
they have made clear who they are
character-wise your sister has
and for even entertaining that and
has made clear as to what position you
play in that relationship
which is i'm gonna ask you to do things
that i
know violate your core values i'm gonna
tattle on you
to my mommy if if you don't do the
things that i want you to do
even though they violate your core
values and then i'm gonna steal from my
kid
you've got all you need to know and i
know it's your sister and i know that's
hard
but dude you've got all the information
you need to know
right right it is hard because i know
that
going forward the relationship there
would be
it just would have been so much harder
to say no which
i know but sounds coming out of my mouth
yeah you're giving her so much power
she is a broken outlet she is an outlet
with no power in it
and with only one of the prong slots
open and you're still trying to figure
out how to get your plug into that
outlet
like you know what i'm saying she's a
person of no character
and i hate to say that about somebody's
family member like that hurts to say
that out loud
but she's not a person of character you
are and so
you are feeling bad about a a fracture
in a relationship
and you're the you're you're a full plug
you're the person of integrity
and so the the relationship is what i'm
telling you isn't what you thought it
was
and my hope is you can be free of this
now
not free of your sister i don't want you
to to
you know hate on your sister destroy
that or but you've been carrying around
for a
long time the weight and responsibility
of peacekeeping between you and your
sister
and you've been carrying around the
phrase a long time
the weight of responsibility the
triangulation of peacekeeping between
you your sister and your mom
and your sister is not a person of
integrity or character
she's going to steal from her sister
from her child to pay for
dog surgery
yeah that she could afford it's nonsense
it's a character issue right and so what
i want to tell you is this
you're free of it you are free to speak
your mind
you are free to be as honest as you can
you are free to say these are my core
values and if you are not a good person
and here's the deal
my guess is this is not the first time
my guess is this has been a pattern
over the course of your relationship
history with her
and you've been trying to hold this
thing together for so long
you're free you're free you are free
and if she says hey i'm taking out a
credit card and my kids i think i'm
gonna be able to figure that out
you can tell her you are a freaking
thief
what kind of human being steals from
their child
what kind of person does that who takes
their kids
social security number and gets a credit
card
a line of credit an illegal line of
credit
on the back of a 10 year old or an 11
year old or a six year old
for anything much less a dog surgery
ridiculous so today samantha you are
free
speak your heart your mind i want you to
really get deep
with yourself about what your core
values are
i want you to begin speaking up for
yourself with your mom
and listen if you lose quote-unquote
lose one of them
right if your sister says well if that's
how you feel i'm not quite talking to
you
good riddance she's already made her bed
you are a
pawn in her game right you're a chess
piece for her
you are someone to call when she doesn't
want to do things
the right way she you are somebody that
will get her what she needs
um when it's convenient for her and
that's not a person of integrity and
again
i hate saying that about somebody's
sister ah that sucks sucks sucks
ugh i'm so blessed with my family geez
louise
thank you so much for that call samantha
i hate that for you but i'm also
excited for you you're free you're free
fly like a bird
all right let's go to mary in
fayetteville
arkansas what's up mary how are we doing
hi how are you so good what's going on
this morning
okay so i am 27
my husband is 26. we've been together
for a decade but we just
got married three months ago we have a
four-year-old daughter
and i'm working two jobs 65 hours a week
and he's working he's working part-time
and that's it um
that was i'm not laughing at you sort of
i'm laughing with you
um yeah but kind of at you
and the way you said that was awesome
just and that's it
so how can i help today i'm sure there's
a bunch of ways i could help but
not gonna help well he also he wants to
go to school for something technical
so he can start a good career okay and
be making most of the money and
i am wanting to just like get an
apartment so we can like
we're living in his parents old house
rent-free okay
um so do they live in the house too is
it just y'all too
no it's just us too and our daughter
okay and
um i'm just wanting to move out and get
an apartment i found one
it's 25 of my take-home pay
um we haven't combined incomes because
he's kind of against that
which so and normally in these
situations
i would walk through a series of
questions
like that start with your husband
your new husband of three months sounds
like he is
um a child sounds like he's a teenager
and he's still living in a teenage mind
i'm gonna be honest with you when i got
married i got married really young
i still had a teenage mind i still had a
idea that i was just gonna go to work
and then go to the gym and
like my wife was a glorified roommate i
hadn't wrapped my head around it yet
okay
and so i don't want to to hop all over
this guy yet
but you're the person i'm talking to
and so my question to you is you've
known this dude for a decade
he's been the father of your daughter
for four years certainly this isn't a
surprise
no it's not so you married him knowing
that
this was who you were getting right it's
not like he bait and switched you right
mm-hmm
what do you want me to do he has grown
up
um his parents were paying most of his
bills he is slowly taking them
on but my problem is i want to get an
apartment
so that we can just kind of jump off the
cliff and land on our own feet instead
of
constantly having that extra help that
they
give him um i refuse help from my
parents even if i need it like i'll sell
stuff
online you know like i obviously got
another job
so so it's before you just jump off
anything
you guys have to have a plan because one
of you is going to jump and the other
one's not going to
or one of you is going to jump and
you're going to grab the other one and
drag them down
and that always ends up just in a pile
of bodies at the bottom of a cliff
okay and have you ever
like sat down with him and said what's
your vision for this thing
and i know that may sound ridiculous to
some women listening to this
thinking about the guys that they're
with right now and i know there are guys
mowing their yards or driving right now
listening is going
dude i cannot have a w what is our
vision conversation with my wife
she would never have that conversation
so put yourself in that
in in that space you and him go camping
one weekend and it's just like
dude what are we doing what would that
conversation be like or
maybe you've had it i did have that this
past weekend
and he he's very optimistic he's like
yeah i'm gonna go to college and get
this career and then
you can quit your jobs and stay home and
you know all that so
on monday of this week did he start
looking up colleges and
and sending applications because it's
not christmas he can be in a program by
january
right yeah he he has and his mom and him
have talked
but that's the thing is like she's
constantly helping him she's like okay
i'll pay for your college
instead of letting him like think about
how he could do it
well i'm not if if a parent is going to
reach out and be supportive
i don't want to just say no to that out
of hand right if it comes with strings
and it comes with expectations
that mom is going to continue to run
your new married life
yeah i'm not taking that money and i'm
going to be really vocal in my home
about my spouse
taking that money but if a parent's
gonna help
that in and of itself isn't a bad thing
and so you have a young kid you have a
young marriage
and mom says hey i'll help with tuition
but son you're gonna have to work your
butt off and you're gonna have to really
problem is she's willing to pay it she's
always paid for like
everything i know but here's the thing
you knew this coming in
i know and so part of me well i mean my
heart's broken away the
bad qualities because i saw the good i
saw the good qualities
are the good still there oh yeah they're
still yeah
so at the end of the day let's take like
the work thing is a big deal for me
everyone like we were made to work um
not working leads to all kinds of
downstream mental health issues
and relational challenges and just in
like self-worth
issues male female everybody deals with
this
but let's back up is he a good dad does
he love you
yes yes he's a great dad he loves that
little baby
yep and i've got two definitions i love
one that talks about a lot
and one that shows up and shows up looks
like getting a job
shows up also looks like getting up in
the middle of the night and changing
diapers and
being supportive when wife is off
working 65 hours a week
cleaning bottles making sure dinner's
ready so he helps with that kind of
stuff
yes he does that's awesome okay so what
you're telling me is you've got a guy
that's got integrity and character
and he doesn't have the tools yes
right and so two things one he needs to
call me
so i can talk directly to him okay
because you and i can't solve his
problem
right what you and i can do is this
number one
at some at some existential level 35 000
foot view of this
you knew the bed you were you were
getting into right
you knew and so what you're asking him
to do
is to make a decade a character change
overnight after three months
you're asking him to become a different
person it's a fair ask and it's a right
ask but it is a tall order at this point
right
yeah and so what i want you to do is
to set up so you guys had the
conversation this weekend that's not a
one-off shot
so today i want you to say
i want to follow up on our conversation
we had this weekend
saturday morning we're going to let
grandma come pick up
our four-year-old or we're gonna let
four-year-old i don't know play
four-year-old things or when
four-year-old takes nap number one
um in the morning we're gonna we're
gonna meet we're gonna go on the front
porch
it's not super freezing yet in arkansas
here we're gonna go out on the front
porch
and we are going to talk through this
because um we're going to set up some
metrics
right we've got the dream part you said
you want to go to school you want to
have a job
and you want me to be able to stay home
awesome then we're going to start
putting things in order
when are you going to first send off
your applications
i'm expecting you that we're going to
start school
january so we're going to get some child
care issues i want you to start putting
some meat on that skeleton
okay okay and that means for the next
couple of days until you have that
meeting
i want you to be thinking about the
things in your mind that you want
answered
what's the date on this who's going to
pay for it what's the
time expectation let's look at your
schedule because we're going to get a
schedule
and for a technical school in
fayetteville that's a sign up sheet
right there's
a couple of giant universities there oh
yeah and there are some technical
schools all around that area
you're going to get signed up you could
have a course list
by friday you could have a course list
by first thing next week literally
signed up
ready to go and then you're gonna have
to figure out scheduling right are you
gonna cut back on your job are you gonna
keep working and you're gonna need some
help from the in-laws
all those kind of things and you're
gonna have to get over your pride part
you're a newlywed couple you've got a
little baby
let grandparents help you if it's
healthy don't just say no just to say no
right that that ends up being here's the
thing it ends up being the same
issue just on the way other side of the
spectrum
like yeah i need all the help i need
none of your help
it's both silly okay yeah and one feels
tougher than the other
they're not they're both inaccurate you
both need a little bit of help you're a
newlywed couple
even though you've been together forever
you've got a newborn in that house and
you are still trying to figure out
what life's gonna look like so accept
the help if it doesn't come with a bunch
of
character and value strings to it okay
and then i want you to ask him the
following
uh i want you to ask him for permission
to hold him accountable
i want you to ask him um the following
hey i'm asking a lot of you because
you're gonna have to be a different guy
now
we're married we have a baby you're
gonna have to
begin to break away from your mom and
i'm asking
if i can speak into your life as your
wife
i'm asking you to when you get nervous
and frustrated
to not hide with video games to not just
quit school
but come tell me and say i'm being
vulnerable here and i don't know how to
do this because mom never made me
dad didn't teach me how but i'm kind of
exhausted right now
and then you can give him the speech i'm
working 65 hours i'm exhausted y'all can
do that that y'all can have that dance
together
but i want you to tell him proactively
i want to be a part of helping us come
together i want to be a part of helping
you become a great
great husband become a great man and i
know it's going to be a journey for us
because you've been this way for a long
time
and i'm all in if you're all in i want
him i want you to tether into him
okay okay and then man you be
you be firm on the accountability let's
get some dates let's get some dollar
amounts let's get some here's what this
is going to do to our schedules
let's get some of that on paper on the
calendar and then let's get ready to
rock and roll
and again he sounds like a guy of
integrity and character that has just
simply been mothered to death and he's
got no tools
and you signed up for it you knew what
you were getting you signed up for it
um you're gonna have to be about
teaching him tools and you're gonna have
to let him
grow up and you're gonna have to hold
him accountable and you're gonna have to
let him hold you accountable
okay awesome mary i've got high faith in
you guys
i got high faith in you even though you
jumped into a pool knowing there was no
water in it
you knew there was no water in it but
you jumped anyway all right so it hurt
when you hit
and now we're gonna get up dust our
stuff off and we're gonna get into the
business of being connected so good for
you mary
guys get jobs
go to work figure it out go to work go
to work go to work
go to work i'll just say it again guys
go to work
go do it my friend ken coleman has a
whole show about going to work go to
work
all right let's go to you know what
i feel like i want to talk about
something for a second
i want to talk about something that is
super unpopular and it's going to make
me a dork
right but i'm experiencing this right
now
and i know you're experiencing it
because i read the data number one i
take the calls number two
i still am taking coaching calls in the
evenings with folks all across the
country
that i've got connections with
everybody's dealing with this
and it's not what you think it's going
to be the big overarching thing is we
are struggling from anxiety disorders
all over the place
40 million people have some sort of
anxiety disorder
and those are the counted ones those are
not people who are just
dealing with elevated heart rate all the
time elevated cortisol and adrenaline
levels
elevated all kinds of things snapping at
people that they normally wouldn't snap
at just constantly like red-eyed and
glued into everything
beneath anxiety is often this
i haven't slept well in a few nights
in fact i slept in the guest room
because my diet has gone to trash for a
few days
i stayed glued into the election stuff i
wanted to see how it was
what was going on how it was all playing
out
i've been checking stuff more than i
normally do
and i'm always looking for ways to help
people change your relationship with
anxiety and one of the cornerstones
for helping your brain calm down right
because anxiety is just an alarm system
saying that your
ecosystem is out of whack
is you got to get sleep the most
powerful non-pharmaceutical remedy for
anxiety in the world
bar none is sleep and think about this
50 60 70 some say a hundred years ago
we literally just lopped off 25 to 30
percent of our sleep
when it got dark a few months ago
uh a tornado came through my new area my
new home and we were out with out of
power i live out in the country so we
had no power
i didn't have any water we had no
satellite and my phones run through the
satellites we had nothing i had nothing
nothing
and it was just dark and then i looked
at my wife and said i guess we're just
going to go to bed
and i had the greatest night of sleep
there was nothing going on there was no
satellites there was no nothing there
was nothing
we had just lopped off sleep as though
it didn't matter we used to sleep eight
nine ten hours a night because it was
dark we slept with the seasons
now we sleep five and a half six and a
half hours i want
everyone to read or find a podcast
with dr matthew walker he's the author
of a book why we sleep
he's a researcher and neuroscientist he
is the guru when it comes to sleep
he's the guru of what has happened over
the last 100 years 50 60 years where we
have just
increasingly cut off sleep more and more
and more and more
a single night of poor sleep can impair
a body's response
it can make us um unable to fight off
sickness
it lets our frontal lobe stay completely
untethered
right his research reveals that a lack
of sleep amplifies anxiety level
and healthy amounts of sleep decrease
anxiety period
they have tracked sleep and track sleep
and track sleep and they measure
the anxiety levels the next day after a
night of little or no sleep
brain scans show diminished activity of
your brief prefrontal cortex
that's this part of your head that's the
your forehead part that is the ceo of
your brain
sleep is the boss it's
the right thing deep restorative sleep
is like therapy
you just wake up and you can see the
world better
you can feel the world better if you
don't sleep it impairs your
blood sugar it impairs i don't want to
get into all the physiological functions
it just begins to to disrupt everything
right and the deeper
emotional centers of your brain when
your frontal lobe goes offline
they get overactive they start pumping
your body full of chemicals saying run
freeze fight everyone fight everything
right and think about this if you
normally get eight hours
and one night you get only six hours
right that's not uncommon you have a fun
saturday night and you stay up late and
you still get up early on sunday morning
that 25 loss of sleep equates to 80 or
90 percent loss
of rem sleep the good stuff the
restorative stuff
okay so here's a few tips from dr walker
on how to establish healthy sleep
patterns
number one go to bed and wake up at the
same time
every day even after a bad night of
sleep or on the weekend
if you try to always over catch it the
next day right
keep following up following up i only
got four hours last night so i'm gonna
sleep until noon today
you just live in this yo-yo right and
this back and forth back and forth
get up the same time every night if you
had bad sleep the night before get up at
5 30 or 6 30 next morning anyway
you will fall asleep earlier the next
night and your body will begin to catch
itself up
keep your bedroom temperature cool i
have a special box that
runs through a special sheet on my bed
that keeps my bed super super cool
it's awesome but keep your room cool
keep your room cool
an hour before bedtime dim the lights
and turn off all the electronic
screens and devices there's a lot of
research out there
about melatonin response some of it's uh
in blue lights
some of it is sort of shifting and
turning and it may be that
we're keeping our brain engaged the
light research is still coming out
but we have so much stimulation
so much stimulation with shows and
flashing lights and things
i don't know if you guys remember this
but a few years ago i think back in 2017
when the ceo of netflix said his
cheap competitor was sleep he's
literally trying to take sleep away from
people to get them to watch more stuff
more tiger king we don't need it good
folks we don't need it
turn the devices off and if you can't
get sleep if you wake up
or you lay in bed and you lay bed at 10
o'clock and suddenly it's at 10 15 10 30
and you're not it's not happening you're
not going to sleep get up get up go read
a book
get up go for a walk get up do some
coloring books whatever nerd thing write
somebody you love a letter but get up
don't just sit there and toss and turn
and toss and turn
do something quiet and relaxing until
the urge to sleep returns
and then go back to sleep another thing
is man
we just guzzle caffeine over and over
and over
avoid caffeine after one and this has
been a big one for me i read this in the
research a few years ago
i didn't believe it and it's made a huge
difference for me
alcohol is a sedative it makes you
unconscious it doesn't help your sleep
alcohol blocks your rem dream sleep
which is the important
recharge therapeutic part of sleeping
and so when you drink
you go unconscious it puts you down but
you never get to that deep restorative
sleep
so over the last couple years my alcohol
intake has just dramatically cut
off just because i don't feel good
anymore and i started watching it closer
and closer and closer
so avoid caffeine after 1 pm have your
coffee have in the morning there's some
there's some great benefits to coffee
but don't just drink it all day all day
all day
i can do it at night i just have i just
have you know espresso at night it
doesn't even affect me
i promise it affects you cut back on
your alcohol intake and then there's a
bunch of different supplements and i'll
leave that between you and your doctor
one last thing i want to say about sleep
kids in sleep
the research on what we are doing to our
children's brains by making them get up
at six o'clock in the morning to catch a
bus to go to school it starts at 6
50 or 7 10 or 7 20 is
criminal we're killing our kids
with the amount of sleep we are stealing
from them
be a vocal proponent of a later start
time and i know that affects work
schedules and all that
that's for politicians and smarter
people than me to figure out
i know that it's not cool to make your
kid go to bed early
i know that i get it it's a fight
but man once your kids start being able
to experience what 10
11 hours of sleep is like you're going
to get a renewed child you're going to
get a renewed thinker
a young kid who's able to learn and
process things
golly dude you're talking about
transforming communities from the floor
up
and don't forget teenagers do their
their
their sleep patterns begin to shift and
so they do naturally start to go to bed
a little bit later
and want to sleep in a little bit longer
that's okay that's normal
read the book and do your own homework
on you and your family
but i want to really press on you be
hyper
freakishly attentive to how much sleep
your kids are getting
crazy amount of sleep add two hours to
it just cause
right and then you've got to walk the
walk to
you've got to start looking at how much
you're on screens right before bed
how much stimulation and excitement's
going on in your house before bedtime
and i want you to just try try for 30
days just turning stuff off
turning the stuff off and see if you
don't begin to get some sleep if you
don't begin to feel better think better
and over time be way way less anxious
all right so that's my
that's my my thoughts on sleep anxiety
go to sleep all right let's go to one
more call let's go to leslie in st
louis missouri leslie what's up
good morning how are you um i'm good i'm
good thanks for taking my call and
um i definitely wanted to say thank you
to the ramsey team for bringing you on
board you have definitely
spoken to my heart through a lot of your
podcast so i appreciate that thank you
so much for that kindness i appreciate
that
so how can i help you today so my
question um for you is
how my husband and i have really
struggled um
in our marriage um most recently just
within the last two and a half years
after our son was born um and
my husband is constantly saying like you
know i just need you to respect me more
i need you to respect me more
and what does that mean i have a very
um does that mean do whatever i want and
what i say
um no i think he
in his eyes he wants me to
maybe put him first and i have
no problem doing that um but
a lot of times in my eyes he
does not do anything um to
deserve it or um
put me first or our marriage or our son
first um how long have you been married
we've been married um it'll be four
years um
this coming 2021. so is this
is this new for him it's like it's
emerged over the last couple years did
things change when you had a kid
or has he always been pretty much
women need to know their role and this
is how my house is going to run
no no he's not like that okay um
he's not like that um he is just
um
it's it honestly it's mostly when our
when our son was about five or
four or five months old um he
might my husband is kind of just um
and dave has on had talked about the
enneagram
on the show so i got the book my husband
is
an eight like his face showed up when i
read chapter eight
like that is my son or that is my
husband and
um he is in
um law enforcement and i think that a
lot of his
um personality comes from the anxiety
and the stress of his job
which i clearly understand um but
i too am a full-time working healthcare
professional and i work
more than full-time um and
i come home and i do all the things
the only thing my husband contributes to
our marriage
and parenthood is his paycheck and
it's heartbreaking yeah um
he's he's just not a warm and fuzzy
place to come home to
um have you told him this yes
and how did that conversation go like
when you sat down
not in a fight and but in a what i would
call an intimate moment and said
hey look i know your job is really hard
and for the past couple of years it has
been super hard
both existentially practically
it's been really tough you're there in
st louis you all have gotten
it worse on top of worse on top of worse
right yeah
brutal all sides telling your husband
both explicitly and implicitly you're
kind of worthless
and he has a kid which throws
a wrench in the gears of every marriage
good ones
heart broken marriages all of them
having a kid is hard
and then he's got a wife who's working
full full full time on top of
another job right um and you're picking
up your share of trauma
during all the medical stuff man you've
been living a
zoo too so i'm hearing that that's a lot
of
conflict a lot of storms a lot of stuff
and you sit down and you walk this
through with him
and then say i need you to be a warm
person
to come home to i need to be able to
fall into
you i need you to be there to catch me
because i love you and i'm going to be
there to catch you and his response is
what
well i'm just not a touchy-feely person
or you know and that's that's kind of
what he says like
you know i want to you know when he
comes home i want to give him a hug
and show him you know i'm glad you're
home and he
every time i go to hug him comes up with
an excuse to not hug me
or if i want to go to kiss him he'll
kind of roll his eyes that he has to
um kiss me or so is there other is there
other things going on
no no um you know not that i'm aware of
i mean
he's he's do you have a strong intimate
life
no no um
he thinks that i'm he says that he's
distant from me
because i'm critical okay um is there
some truth
is there some truth to that um i think
there
is but it's i think that there is but
it's because i'm
constantly telling him like i need you
to show up and help me with our son
i need you to show up and help me with
this and
like and so here's here's what happens
here's what happens
you get into a dance where suddenly you
sound
very similar to the sergeant he works
for
or you sound very similar to his mom
and he suddenly becomes very similar to
every stereotypical police officer he
becomes
um he becomes very similar to
probably men that you've had in your
life in the past whether that's your dad
or your brother's
this distant cycle and your role in that
is to slowly begin to point out what he
needs to be doing which turns into
what something like a job performance
review which turns very quickly into
complaining
frustration not that it's not warranted
but it just turns into this cycle
and he turns into because right now i
guarantee you he's thinking in his head
my home isn't a warm place for me to
come home to
and now y'all now you're locked into a
figure eight that you can't get out of
right right and because he's right too
he comes home and he gets a list of job
chores
and he just wants to sit for a minute
and you're thinking rightfully
you can't sit i've been working all day
i'm exhausted
i need help with dinner hey look you
have a child over here why don't you go
love that
right and it just gets into this
loop-de-loop-de-loop-de-loop
and it's heartbroken heartbroken
heartbreaking and one of you
if not both of you have to turn
and bravely face that dance
otherwise it just grinds you down and
that's when you're gonna
take that flirty text with somebody else
one step too far that's where he's gonna
end up just staying out later and lit
right and that's when you end up
with this wedge between your marriage or
you end up
40-year roommates that's just the way he
is that's just the way i am and you live
a silent
burning simmering life and he lives
a distant hit the recliner pro my feet
up life
and both of you are worth more than that
but both of you are going to have to
lean
way into the discomfort and since i'm
only talking to you
the only person you can handle on this
end is you
right and at some point you're going to
have to say
i love you more than life itself and i
also love our baby
and i don't want to be somebody who's
acts like your mom
i don't want to be someone who nags you
i want to create a world that's a warm
safe like haven from the world
that ugly place that your husband wades
into every day on behalf of his
community
on behalf of his state and his country
i want to create a safe warm place for
you when you get home
and for me to do that here's what i need
and approach it from
here's how i want to lean into you but
i've got to have you leaning back
as and that's a different approach then
if you would just do these things then
this would does that make sense
one is a tethering in and one is a job
performance
one is a like a ceo review right
and here's the thing i've worked with
police officers for a long time
no one no one no one will ever know what
they go through
and i've also worked with healthcare
professionals for a long long time
no one will ever know what they go
through
and i can't recommend strongly enough
that you two
the conversations start with you because
you're the only person you can control
i wish he would do it but he won't
i wish uh you're gonna have to lean into
that at the beginning
and say here's what i need and you're
you all two are at a point now where
y'all need to go see somebody
right and i have i have been seeing
someone and he won't or
or he's open to it sort of ish okay no
okay nope that's that's weak ah okay
i've loved loved love those those police
officers my whole life
and it's heartbreaking it's hard but
i've i've known those guys and they've
got great hearts
and there's there comes a moment when
if they open that door there's a fear
that i can never close it again and i
understand that
from the stuff they've seen the stuff
they've experienced their childhood
stuff all of it
so at the end of the day you can work on
you
and you can continue to model and lean
in what i'm going to tell you is
nagging complaining fighting solves
nothing ever it becomes a burden that
you carry
and if he will call me i'll tell him the
reverse of that
demanding respect without earning it
demanding
warmth without giving it
again as a fool's errand it never works
right
and at the end of the day both of you in
your own weird
loving ways are choosing the misery that
you are both living in
and i hate that for you
okay until he decides
that he wants to deeply connect with you
at the end of the day all you can work
on is you i wish i had a more optimistic
thing to tell you
i can tell you this though i can tell
you this leslie
i've sat with a lot of police officers a
lot of them
who have made some extraordinary moves
in their life
one of the chief mentors in my life in
the crisis world dr andy young
works almost exclusively with police
officers behind closed doors
and helping heal marriages and helping
heal hearts and helping
those guys deal with the extraordinary
stress that they're under
all the time every day and so i'm going
to tell you
that growth and and wellness is super
possible
it takes some work but it's super
possible and it's the furthest thing
from weak
weakness is running weakness is hiding
facing those old demons those old
dragons that's the hard stuff right
that's that's bravery
and so have your husband call me i'd
love to talk to him he won't call me but
i'd love to talk to him and
if not um i want you to not give up on
him
keep loving him keep doing the things
that you know
make you well don't give in to the
temptations of
somebody else outside your marriage
that's not going to heal you don't give
in to the temptations
of just completely disconnecting that's
not going to heal you
continue to be honest with him continue
to show up continue to tell him
i love you and i want to make this a
warm safe place for you to come home to
and it's going to be exhausting and it's
going to take energy you probably don't
have
because you're a kick and butt nurse
you're a contingent or kicking butt i
just said that
you may be a surgeon you're a kicking
butt health professional and you're a
full-time mom too
and that's a lot
it's a lot my hope and prayer for you is
that this is a season
this is a hard season um and that you
and your husband are going to find each
other
but all you can do is take care of you
so keep seeing a a counselor
keep leaning into it and keep leaning
into the relationship
and that's all you can do
i'm sorry leslie those those
conversations break my heart because
here's the thing good folks
men listening to this women listening to
this single people couples
it's a decision at the end of the day
it's a decision when your wife leans in
to kiss you that you turn your face
because
she's not feeling the blame it's a
decision
when your husband gets home from a crazy
day of work even if you're tired
to not go over there and hug him that's
a choice
it's a choice to just stay at home while
she's out working two jobs and you
thinking
well i just got to find the right
opportunity for no dude go do something
that's a choice
it's a choice to not say hey we haven't
slept together
in a month and things are really weird
and i'm uncomfortable and i don't know
what to do next
but i don't like this one of you has to
say it first
it sucks but at the end of the day it's
a choice
both people are choosing to live like
this guys and you don't have to do it
you're worth being in a relationship
you're worth being well
you're worth being loved man everybody
is worth being loved
all right that's it um i'm gonna wrap it
up with the song of the day
this is almost a fitting song
almost a fitting song this is from one
of my favorite records of all time it
came out of nowhere
a guy recorded this with cheap
microphones acoustic guitar
some interesting arrangements and it
ended up taking the world by storm back
in 2002
the title of the record is simply oh
by an extraordinary songwriter named
damian rice
and the song is called cannonball and he
writes
there's still a little bit of your taste
in my mouth and a
still a little bit of you laced with my
doubt
it's still a little harder to say what's
going on
there's still a little bit of your ghost
your witness still a little bit of your
face i haven't kissed
you step a little closer each day that i
can't say what's going on
stones taught me to fly and love
taught me to lie in life it taught me to
die so it's not hard to fall
when you float like a cannonball
stones taught me to fly love it taught
me to lie
life taught me to die so it's not hard
to fall
when you float like a cannonball this
has been the dr john deloney show